guys I am so excited that you are here
I feel like cheer has just taken over an
insane life of its own
what's the reception been like there's
been a lot of positivity just coming and
all of the doors that have opened all of
the people we've gotten the privilege of
meeting and just like how heartwarming
it is to know like we've inspired like
so many people I didn't think that it
was gonna blow up the way it did and
I've run so many like messages from
people that I don't even know like that
are like saying that they would like die
for me like there's so many like really
kind people out there that really just
want to see us doing good yeah it just
feels really amazing the amount of love
and positivity that people have shown us
is truly incredible because we really
don't think how much we impact others
until they reach out and actually let us
know that we've done something to them
so it's just been a complete blessing
and we're so happy that we've been able
to do that for people yeah I mean you
guys have touched so many people's
hearts and lives I'm curious how you
guys feel about how you were each
portrayed on the show like do you think
it was accurate was it strange to watch
yourselves back it was it was accurate
for the most part I think towards the
end they kind of like painted me out to
look like I was messing it up really
badly the rape scene that they put in
the last episode actually happened
months before Daytona and they made it
look like that's all I was doing when I
left and it's not the case but
everything else like they did a really
amazing job of like telling that story I
feel like I betrayed me very well I'm
gonna say in the clips that I would have
had a problem with and I'm very happy
with what they did yeah yeah for me I
feel like it was it was very accurate
for me the only thing also that I would
say is they did portray my parents to be
a little a little intense which we we
can our family is not the norm
we are definitely far from perfect but I
think for as parents I'm
mean there's a fine line between
overstepping and caring parents and I
think that after the show came out
obviously it did open all of our eyes
and there were things that we were like
oh well maybe we need to be better at
this and maybe we can you know relax in
this aspect and also for me it opened my
eyes to be more positive and just think
more highly of myself I'm just grateful
for all of the opportunities we've had
and I think that the show has brought a
lot of positivity and I think they
really did a great job with just showing
everything that makes cheer cheer yeah
absolutely I would agree with that I do
kind of want to get life updates from
each of you individually and some of you
have already sort of touched on a little
bit of that but we're gonna go down the
line I guess I'll start with you Lexi
you did leave Navarro now you are back
what conversations did you have with
Monica to get back onto the team well um
basically whenever I was going to the
other college I just didn't feel like it
was a good fit for me I wasn't really
like I didn't have that at home feeling
that I did when I was there I was at
Navarro Monica's been like the type to
in the past she's given second chances
and she she like knew that like my
intentions like weren't bad and that I
did really want to like you know prove
myself that I like am I'm not like the
bad decisions that I've made I'm better
than that
so she was open to like giving me
another chance and I'm really thankful
she did because life's been so crazy and
like just crazy in a good way since I've
been back
did watching the documentary inspire you
to get back into cheer definitely I
think that's one of like the major
reasons why I wanted to come back was
just like watching it like put me on
such an emotional like roller coaster
because last year really was an
incredible year but like getting to
rewatch it and relive that like it made
me want to like come back and experience
all of that all over again because it's
like an undescribable amazing feeling
Jerry your turn to be in the hot seat
you went to Louisville for a minute I
did and I'm getting accepted to
Louisville so I decided to go
which was your dream school it was my
dream school but I was there it wasn't
all I expected it to be so I was I
wanted to go back to that family aspect
of Navaro so I reached out to Monica I'm
seeing if she had any room for me and
luck is luckily she did and I decided to
seize that opportunity to make myself
happy so happy to see you guys back
there what was your conversation like
with Monica like did you have to explain
yourself at all or no I don't really I
don't have to explain myself I think it
was more so she was just so excited to
have me back because she just loved like
the person that I was I think it was
more so like me figuring out like if I
was actually gonna be able to like make
this a thing so it was me coming to
terms with if I actually want to do this
versus me just talking about it yeah so
she gave me time to like really think
about it and once I get in a decision I
just let them know and then that was
that people really resonated with your
story and what you've been through and I
think we're so inspired by how positive
you always are and how you go and you
inspire other people how do you do it I
think it really just comes from my mom
like growing up with her she just told
me to always be positive and always try
to do the right thing and I think I just
take that with me every single day and
try to live vicariously through her and
just give that to others and be the
light and other people's life that she
was in my life so do you think about
what she would make of all of this she
would be so happy see what I know what
to do oh my gosh Wow that's crazy I can
tell you I mean it I mean it sounds so
cheesy but like you're doing her proud I
mean you really thank you so much you're
amazing Gavin you ready yeah you sort of
touched on this a little bit but
obviously your parents were a big part
of your storyline how did they feel
watching it back so I feel like as a
family we are very very we talk all the
time now we're very open with each other
we're there
very tight-knit family so there are
times that I'm like you guys can just
breathe chill a little bit and there are
times listen I'm I'm not perfect either
by any means I'm I am lazy sometimes I
don't know it in a way I feel like all
the chaos has brought positivity and I
feel like we're a lot closer as a family
and I feel like we're we've always been
super good at communicating but now I
feel like it's just it's even better
with my whole entire family I feel like
we're really trying to just be the best
we can be and obviously no family's
perfect sure my parents would do
absolutely anything for me did you get a
break after all of this girl yes not
much time because my schedule is so so
like tight with cheerleading but yeah I
took like two days just like to myself
went to the beach had a little picnic
Florida perfect for the beach I have my
sunglass I had a little picnic of fruit
and I was just chillin I'm like yeah
this is good this is what I need yeah
but your next break I want it to be you
two weeks
Oh what is the gabbie Empire look like
to you when you think about your future
honestly my life is very uh I just kind
of go with the flow of things like I
never plan my life out which I feel like
I need to like kind of get better at but
as of right now I'm actually cheering at
this place called Top Gun All Stars and
went on your Instagram yeah and they're
in Miami Florida
that's actually the gym that I started
like cheerleading at so are you no
longer with Navarro technically yeah so
technically I'm not with Navarro right
now can you go back or have you sort of
maxed out or so I technically have one
more year because I've done two years
and
everyone's going back and everyone's
like oh is she going back is she going
back are you gonna go back eat it loosen
is she gonna go back I just told Monica
I was like listen you if anything ever
happens just know I'm I'm here I'm your
backup if someone gets hurt if something
it was to come up and let's say someone
was not able to do it I would always but
that's the only way you would go back
someone faked an injury I mean it's kind
of like it's I'm like I'm much
okay but yeah as I right now I'm
cheering at Top Gun and it's like an
hour from my house and it's in Miami and
I love it it's very fun and it's all
stars so we don't go against Navarro but
okay it's really really fun well I do
want to know so you will not compete at
Daytona
2020 Oh sounds like she's gonna go back
[Laughter]
yes uh are you guys in a compete at
Daytona
yeah they talked about this in the
docu-series about how the life of a
cheerleading career isn't like the NFL
or the NBA so what do you guys see next
for yourselves like what's the dream
personally for me I've always had a huge
passion for art and I love drawing I
love painting I just recently got into
digital art and I love design so like no
matter what I do I know that I want to
like let my creative side show and I'm
not truly gonna I'm not gonna settle for
a career where I don't get to like put
my artwork out there sure and you're
really good we saw some of it great yeah
Jerry um well chilling is my passion it
has been ever since I was a baby um so I
will forever be in the chair industry
whether I'm coaching or being a
choreographer in judging I'm gonna be in
the chair forever thank you thank you so
much but since the show came out has
been off a lot of doors have open and so
many opportunities have been thrown my
way so I'm gonna do my best to seize
them but always remember where my
passion lies and this was cheers so do
you think Monica will hire you honestly
I feel like what Jerry was saying
there's been a lot of doors that have
been opened and honestly as long as I'm
passionate about it I I'm down to do
whatever and wherever life takes me
I do love like the movie industry and
all the you know action II things and I
used to talk about wanting to be a stunt
double oh yeah yeah it's I know it's
like a little dangerous and risky but
like I'm very I think I'm very very
courageous and I think that yeah
I mean wipe ourselves like 30 feet in
the air so I mean it's not that much can
I get really any more scary than that
but I can definitely see myself and also
I do love cheer it does bring out a side
of me that I feel like is always just
positive and it really does open me up
to everybody a lot more and so I I guess
it's just kind of up in the air as of
right now but I whatever life throws at
me I'm gonna I'm gonna really take the
opportunity and just do it
our cameras currently following you guys
well TMZ was out there but I mean in
like a docu-series like a season two
cents you know we're just really excited
for season one and we just really are
focusing on this and just loving all the
love that we're getting from this show
so would you want a season two I want to
be a post I mean yeah it's a I think the
first season obviously I mean it's a hit
and I think the whole country can agree
I feel like everybody's talking about it
so of course I you know I think a season
two would be amazing I think it's super
hard because it's so like the season one
is so good so it's like oh how are we
gonna top season one but seriously it's
we'll see do you think they should ever
follow a different school if there was
it to be another
now if we're gonna be super honest I
have cheered at so many places and I
feel like there is nothing like tomorrow
and that is true there is nothing like
it yeah and until you're like actually a
part of it
you don't like understand how special it
is part of what makes it special is
obviously Monica absolutely so I want to
know from your guys's perspective is
there a phrase or something that she's
told you that's really stuck with you in
your life
she definitely says a lot I feel like
Monica not only is an amazing coach but
she's an amazing mentor and I feel like
she's someone that we can look for in
any guidance or any life tips at all and
I think I mean if you she said so many
things but she's always you know telling
us be better than you were yesterday and
just you know like yesterday was
yesterday and you you you can only go up
from here
she always encourages you to like hold
yourself to a higher standard and just
prison yourself as like a professional
she also taught me you are on time today
I have to say the biggest thing she's
has taught me is to always plan for
everything you know cuz if you plan for
things you'll always know what's coming
up and you won't ever forget it anything
that's that you may have coming up so
that's one of the big things I always
just plan for everything um a lot of
celeb fans you guys Reese Witherspoon I
never see crazy
simone biles asked if you could join
Navarro after the 2020 Olympics I mean
what do you make of all of that well
first of all we're gonna you got to get
her on the team yeah shot your guys's
tumbling passes together oh yeah she's
absolutely amazing
which celeb shoutout major guys's day
the most or maybe was the most
surprising I had a couple of my favorite
DJ's tweet at me busting Lucy okay I
both loved their music I have to say
it's a lot of people that have sad stuff
the people who everybody stuck out to me
was Snooki in JJ why so Chrissy Teigen
I absolutely loved her and I think she
is so funny so the fact that she
actually made videos watching I'm
stretching and it was thing but it's so
cool to see that like actual like
celebrities watch the show I'm like that
and we never in a million years like
thought that these people would be
watching what are your guys's dm's look
like right now
oh my god because there's so many people
that have sent me like I know there's so
many like paragraphs of like nice things
that people have sent me but there's
just like so overwhelming because of how
many like DMS I've gotten and I just
like wanted to let anyone know that has
DM me that I haven't gotten back to
thank you right yeah being so nice and
supportive and I just like it's like
really amazing to know like so many
people out there like care about yes I
second that I agree if you did me I love
you so much thank you for your love and
support
no seriously like I want to say thank
you to everyone that has shown us love
like we couldn't have been here without
you guys I mean we like this wouldn't
have happened if it wasn't for all of
your support and I think we're just very
grateful for you guys and we love you
and adore you and if again if we can't
get back to you like just no not we
really do appreciate you guys and we all
love you speak that for Nabarro Church
here is I have seen on Twitter people
casting you guys in bio pics already so
we could choose which celebrity were to
play you who would you want oh I don't
know her like real name but a lot of
people have told me I look like their
girl that plays Khaleesi from Amelia
card loved it she would slice cube
played me
[Music]
yeah okay
honestly I I think for me Megan Fox
Jennifer the right thing we do look like
Megan Fox shows incredible and she's
beautiful so that's like the UH oh my
gosh
but I think yeah Megan Fox well like
she's iconic and then Jennifer Lawrence
- I think that she really I feel like me
and her kind of similar in ways and I
think she would absolutely like yeah
yeah I think she would kill it this is a
bag for Monica for sure yeah I saw that
yeah you saw that the side-by-side
gorgeous
[Music]